je pense profondément que le parti
politique à une mission différente des
groupes parlementaires et les aux
parlementaires ont besoin de leur
autonomie en tous les cas celle du sénat
je la défendrai une vôtre et vous leur
envoyez vos travaux pour le révoquer
laurent wauquiez a une capacité une
énergie ce qui est la condition
nécessaire pour réussir une carrière
politique ce n'est pas suffisant il faut
une stabilité dans la ligne et une
stabilité dans le comportement
or laurent jusqu'à présent que je
connais bien et que je l'écouté que je
lis avec beaucoup d'intérêt
manifestement depuis sa première
élection législative cherche sa voie